in the opening scene we are introduced
to a drug addict named Jake who is in
search of a lighter to ignite his cigar
when he is unable to locate it he starts
exploring other means for fire but all
of his attempts are futile in a state of
despair and frustration he decides to
visit the nearest convenience store
hoping to purchase a lighter when he
reaches there he shockingly notices that
everything is in disarray and that there
are no other customers or employees
present however Jake does not pay much
attention to the chaos as he is solely
focused on obtaining a lighter he
eventually locates one and leaves the
money on the counter before exiting the
store a drug addict would never have
done that as he walks back to his home
he begins to notice that the streets are
Barren and devoid of any human life this
causes him to feel bewildered and
perplexed as he is unable to comprehend
how the world could be so empty on the
second day of this strange occurrence
Jake is wandering around when he
stumbles Upon A horrifying sight a
lifeless body of a woman lying under a
bench this freaks him out and he
attempts to call 911 help but his
efforts are in vain the inability to
reach Emergency Services only adds to
Jake's growing sense of unease not long
after his worst fears are confirmed when
he discovers yet another corpse worried
Jake rushes to his family house only to
discover his parents and sisters lying
motionless on the bed damn Full House
overwhelmed by the devastation Jake
begins to question his own sanity and
the reality of the situation he is
unsure if what he's experiencing is real
or simply a hallucination brought on by
his drug use in an effort to snap out of
it he slaps himself repeatedly hoping to
wake up from The Nightmare it is at this
moment that a 13 year old Smart Boy
Named Sam approaches him he reveals that
the world has been struck by a
mysterious sleep epidemic that causes
people to die in their sleep the boy
warns Jake to stay awake or else he'll
end up like everyone else are you a drug
addict too little boy says Jake the
scene then transitions to Jake and Sam
who are joined by two other survivors
Lily and Rachel in order to remain awake
the four have resorted to using various
drugs as well as spending time in the
swimming pool in their conversations
they lament the fact that European
countries have been more fortunate as
the epidemic struck in the morning there
allowing many to survive alcoholism is
pretty rampant over there though so a
lot of people probably slept in and got
pwned anyway however they have no clear
idea of when the epidemic will end or
how they will manage to stay awake in
the long term on the third day Jake and
Sam are conversing when they hear
Rachel's anguished cries for help they
rush to her side only to find that Lily
has fallen asleep and is unresponsive in
a frantic effort to save her they
administer a heavy dose of adrenaline
but it proves to be too late poor Lily
has already passed away in her sleep
panicked Rachel becomes convinced that
the drugs are no longer effective
fearing that they will also come to the
epidemic soon despite Jake's attempts to
calm her down she storms off in the car
taking all the drugs and adrenaline with
her Jake and Sam are left with no choice
but to pursue Rachel in another vehicle
knowing that their own doses of drugs
are wearing off and they'll soon need
more to stay awake however as they
follow Rachel Jake starts falling asleep
rendering him unable to drive with no
other options Sam takes over the
steering and musters the courage to
drive a car for the first time if Short
Round can do it and win an Oscar so can
I in a desperate attempt to keep Jake
awake he stabs him in the leg with a
screwdriver causing him to scream in
pain but also to remain conscious after
a bit of chasing Sam is about to catch
up to Rachel's car but right then a
private jet appears out of nowhere
causing a minor accident this allows
Rachel to escape but fortunately no one
seems to be injured after the crash Jake
and Sam meet the pilot Alice who has
been searching for a way to escape the
epidemic by flying to different cities
Alice is a goddamn Wild Card upon Sam's
request Ellis supplies them with some
adrenaline tablets buying them some time
to stay awake later on the trio heads to
a hospital where they find other
survivors they also meet two doctors
named Ali and Sarah who assist Jake in
treating his wound and provide the group
with a potent dose of adrenaline during
their conversation Ellis reveals that
the Sleep epidemic occurred at different
times in various cities suggesting that
the source of the outbreak lies
somewhere between Houston and Denver
with this new information in hand the
five survivors decide to embark on a
journey to find an answer to the
so-called sleep epidemic after a long
and exhausting Drive the group finally
reaches the City Hospital only to find
it burnt down and abandoned with no
other options left they decide to make
their way to the next Hospital which is
an hour away however Jake suggests
taking a detour to the mortuary located
behind the police station he hopes to
find some useful information there that
can help them in the long run in the
next scene as the group enters the
police station they are taken aback by
the site of a wild party taking place
amidst the chaos it appears as if some
people are trying to make the most of
their limited time everyone knows when
cops confiscate drugs they keep them for
themselves
the group disregards the pope Porgy and
heads to the medical room to search for
information on the epidemic's
progression and death timings meanwhile
Sarah expresses her desire to stay back
and enjoy the party and she believes
that this may be her last chance to do
so at first Ali tries to dissuade her
but ultimately agrees when Jake offers
to look after Sarah as the rest of the
group sets off on their mission Jake and
Sarah start dancing together momentarily
forgetting the dire situation they are
in they're still screwed though in the
medical room Sims technical expertise
allows him to hack into the computer
system where they uncover two points in
time indicating the occurrence of deaths
Ali then explains the concept of spatial
mathematics whereby the intersection of
two reverse azimuths can lead to a final
destination even though she totally made
that word up she is convinced that this
destination is Dallas and the group
agrees to head there meanwhile Jake's
mind is plagued with visions of his
deceased half-sister Megan he follows
her leaving Sarah behind and pours his
heart out to her about his anger towards
his father Jake holds his father
responsible for his mother's ruin
claiming that he spent all of their
money on his second wife rather than
providing child support for Jake and his
mother Jake believes that his mother was
pushed too far by his father ultimately
leading her to commit the unthinkable no
that Downer though back at the party
Sarah begins to feel increasingly drowsy
as the adrenaline in her system depletes
she desperately searches for Jake but to
no avail she becomes more and more
worried Panic sets in after a while Jake
snaps out of his hallucination and
realizes that he needs to return to the
party but when he arrives he finds that
Sarah has already succumbed to her
fatigue and has fallen asleep Ali is
devastated by this and blames Jake for
his negligence Ellis also joins in her
anger agreeing that they can no longer
trust Jake to be a reliable member of
the group fortunately Sam speaks up in
Jake's defense and urges the others not
to abandon him he argues that everyone
deserves a second chance and that they
should not be too quick to judge Jake
based on his recent mistakes plus it was
Sarah's dumbass idea to consume
depressants while trying to stay awake
anyway after much deliberate the group
finally decides to continue their
journey to Dallas but now with only four
members Jake is grateful for Sam's
support and vows to make it up to the
group by being more responsible in the
future on their way their car suddenly
picks up a radio signal a woman's voice
can be heard urging people to go to
Austin where she claims that there is a
cure for their current predicament Ali
recognizes the voice and quickly decides
that they should change their
destination to Austin however Alice
isn't convinced and refuses to change
their plans this prompt dally to decide
to go alone as they are about to part
ways Jake and Sam decide to accompany
Ali as they feel indebted to her for her
loss before departing Alice gives Ali a
device that can track his location if
she is within 100 miles of him the group
then sets off towards Austin unsure of
what they will find there aside from
some pretty damn good barbecue that is
it's the fifth day now and the trio
consisting of Jake's salmon Dolly are
making their way to Austin however an
unexpected and terrifying incident
occurs when a lifeless body falls on top
of their vehicle from an overpass
causing the car to lose control and
collide with a tree this Collision
causes Ali to hit her head and fall
unconscious panicked the boys
frantically start looking for a way to
revive her thankfully Sam finds a bottle
of water and splashes it on Ali's face
causing her to regain Consciousness they
then temporarily bandage her wound to
prevent the loss of blood however with
their car now severely damaged they have
no choice but to continue their Journey
on foot after miles of walking the trio
eventually reached South Austin where
they come across a group of Christian
people who are in the process of
honoring their dad Ali he was extremely
exhausted collapses on the ground
causing Jake and Sam to become very
concerned fortunately the Christian
people spot her and immediately rushed
her to their Parish there they give her
a vetted drink called Salud which
manages to revive her after this Father
Julio who is the leader of the community
introduces himself to the trio and tells
them that they are welcome to stay as
long as they need to while Ali takes
some much needed rest Julio takes Sam
outside and introduces him to some
children his age one of them is Carmen
who shows him around and eventually
leads him to an old blind man named
Edwin Eduardo and his loyal companion a
dog named bullet Sam is amazed at how
the dog has managed to survive in the
harsh conditions it's simple pups don't
rest until we do as bullet barks at the
arrival of Outsiders Eduardo instructs
the kids to return to their parish for
safety however before they can make it
back a disturbed looking man covered in
blood suddenly attacks Carmen stabbing
her arm brutally but before he can harm
her anymore Father Julio and his group
rushed to their aid causing the
Disturbed man to flee it is later
revealed that the man is suffering from
severe sleep deprivation so he has
resorted to self-harm in order to stay
awake this lack of sleep has caused a
significant disturbance to his mental
health resulting in his aggressive
behavior towards others that is
obviously a terrible excuse meanwhile
Carmen is rushed to the parish where
everyone requests Ali to help her the
latter being a radiologist feels
hesitant to perform surgery as she is
not a trained surgeon however given the
dire circumstances she decides to go
ahead and gather the necessary supplies
to perform the surgery on Carmen as they
the operation begins Sam is tasked to
keep Ali awake by engaging her in a
conversation meanwhile Jake decides to
take matters into his own hands and goes
in search of the Disturbed man who has
already murdered another member of the
parish after the successful surgery on
Carmen the group is relieved but their
respite is short-lived when the power
supply suddenly goes out in the parish
believing it to be the generator Julio
heads to investigate but he finds blood
instead indicating that something is
amiss suddenly the Disturbed man
reappears and attacks Julio before
anyone can react the man enters the room
where Ali is curing Carmen posing a
serious threat luckily Jake arrives in
the nick of time and subdues the
attacker killing him in the process
finally the intense situation comes down
as the danger ends and Ali is able to
save Carmen in the final scene we see
the group who decide that it's time for
them to leave and continue their search
for answers they depart in Julio's Car
promising to come back once they have
found the solution to the ongoing
epidemic subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching